[Music]  you're always really outspoken about is  plastic surgery I'm like seriously  contemplating and getting of like a  breast lift slash reduction because I  have like National Geographic food and I  fix it bad you did how do you feel your  just confidence through the roof yeah my  boobs are so cute now are they I love  them so much I mean they're not I'm  still a D like they're not that much  smaller but like my nipples are like  right here so they're so like when I'm  naked like when I get out of the shower  I'm just like that's what's up  that was worth every penny and with all  that newfound confidence looks like we  may see Stassi show it off on the  ballroom floor someday I would love to  do Dancing with the Stars really I love  are you a good dancer I don't think  anymore but I would be so much fun I  like performing so it's you know ABC the  phone we're waiting by the phone here  for Stassi I  [Music]